Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the client. clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever.
你好，我叫贝丝，是一名来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业者。我非常感谢《临床心理学家集体》一书的撰稿人。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位前所拥有的各种背景和经历。看到申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾经非常怀疑自己，不知道自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士学位，但这本书确实给了我所需要的信心，让我决定试一试。所以，真的非常感谢你们。
We've built workplaces that measure performance obsessively, but barely measured whether humans can actually survive within them. And now, employees are burning out sometimes before their careers have even really got started. In this episode, Dr Adam McCartney, educational psychologist and I explore why well-being in organizations is getting harder, how leadership and identity shape mental health at work, and why AI might make all of this even more complicated. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to psychology. Actually, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, and I am joined once again by a friend of the show, Dr. Adam McCartney,
我们建立的工作场所痴迷于衡量绩效，却几乎不衡量人类是否真的能在其中生存。现在，员工有时甚至在职业生涯真正开始之前就已经精疲力竭了。在这一集中，教育心理学家亚当·麦卡特尼博士和我将探讨为什么组织中的幸福感变得越来越难，领导力和身份认同如何塑造工作中的心理健康，以及为什么人工智能可能会让这一切变得更加复杂。希望你觉得这很有用。你好，欢迎来到《心理学，其实不然》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，今天再次邀请到了节目的老朋友，亚当·麦卡特尼博士。
who is a child and educational psychologist. Hi, Adam. Hi, Marian. Great to be back. So lovely to have you here. And for anyone who's like, I've never heard of Adam, Then we have done two episodes already. One was about what is an educational psychologist and kind of looking at kind of vignettes for the types of work that the ed Sykes would do. And the other was about something very interesting called emotionally based school non-attendance, which you might hear discussed as EBSNA or EBSA.
他是一位儿童和教育心理学家。你好，亚当。你好，玛丽安。很高兴回来。很高兴你能来。对于那些说“我从没听说过亚当”的人，我们已经录过两期节目了。一期是关于什么是教育心理学家，并探讨了教育心理学家所做工作的案例；另一期是关于一个非常有趣的话题，叫做“情绪性学校缺勤”，你可能会听到它被称为EBSNA或EBSA。
So there'll be links in the description to that. But with no further ado, let's think about today's topic. So we were chatting in the DMs again on Instagram. So if you don't already follow us on there, please do come and follow us, come and connect with us, share the episodes and tag us too. We love that. So we were thinking actually it would be really interesting to have a little bit of a look from a leadership perspective and from an emerging leaders' perspective about what well-being in organisations really is. So can you tell us a little bit about that, Adam? Yeah, well, as an educational psychologist, this isn't something I thought would be my bag.
描述中会有相关链接。废话不多说，让我们来思考一下今天的话题。我们又在Instagram的私信里聊天了。如果你还没有关注我们，请一定要来关注我们，与我们建立联系，分享节目并标记我们。我们很喜欢这样。所以我们当时在想，从领导力视角和新兴领导者视角来看，组织中的幸福感到底是什么，这会非常有趣。亚当，你能给我们讲讲吗？是的，作为一名教育心理学家，我以前没想过这会是我的专长。
You know, historically, we've been more within child. Every educational psychologist would be cringing, I just said that. But we've increasingly focused on the context of children. And that has meant that we've essentially started having to look at organizations. And the biggest change we've had in the last 20 years is the emergence of multi-academy trusts. and these are essentially businesses that operate within the education sector. And the difference with the education sector is what's called a quasi market is dependent on the amount of funding that a government body gives towards it. It can do little bits and pieces to earn extra pieces, but by and large, it's dependent on how much money the government puts in.
你知道，从历史上看，我们更多地关注儿童。每个教育心理学家听到我刚才说的话都会感到尴尬。但我们越来越关注儿童所处的环境。这意味着我们基本上开始不得不审视各种组织。过去20年里我们经历的最大变化是多学院信托（Multi-Academy Trusts）的出现，这些本质上是在教育领域运营的企业。教育领域与众不同之处在于它被称为“准市场”，它依赖于政府机构提供的资金。它可以做一些小事来赚取额外收入，但总的来说，它取决于政府投入了多少钱。
But within that sector, they operate like businesses. Many multi-chemy trusts have CEOs. and they act like CEOs. They advertise like CEOs. They make business partnerships like CEOs. And that means that a lot of these organizations now operate a bit like the corporate sector. And we have had to then open up, okay, what does leadership look like? What does organizational structure look like?
但在该领域内，它们的运作方式就像企业一样。许多多学院信托都有首席执行官（CEO）。他们的行为像CEO，广告宣传像CEO，建立商业伙伴关系也像CEO。这意味着许多这样的组织现在运作起来有点像企业部门。因此，我们不得不开始探讨：领导力是什么样的？组织结构是什么样的？
And how does all that filter down into the impact for children? I have some understanding of that because I was a parent-guerate. for two years for a primary school. And thankfully, because it was an Academy Trust, I wasn't responsible for the finances because there was an overarching kind of person or department that did that. But I was a safeguarding lead,
这一切又是如何渗透并对儿童产生影响的？我对这一点有一些了解，因为我曾担任过两年小学家长理事。谢天谢地，因为它是学院信托，我不负责财务，因为有一个总管部门或人员负责。但我担任过安全保障负责人，
which is kind of a lot, really, for the responsibility whilst also running a practice, working for the NHS, having children. But this is a way that people can start to develop their own leadership experiences, is thinking about doing voluntary opportunities like that, if they're interested in learning more about this and sharpening their skills to think strategically, really.
这对于在经营诊所、为国民医疗服务体系（NHS）工作、还要照顾孩子的同时承担这些责任来说，确实压力很大。但这是人们开始发展自己领导力经验的一种方式，如果你有兴趣了解更多并磨练自己的技能以进行战略性思考，可以考虑参加这样的志愿机会。
That's what it helped me to do. Okay, thank you, Adam. So tell us about how some of the theories translate into education and perhaps into other settings as well. Yeah, so one of the big theories I came across when I was studying from my doctorate was one call communities, of practice and it's the full titles, the communities of practice of learning, which you would think that lends itself quite well to education, but it's from Lav and Venger who developed in
这就是它帮助我做到的。好的，谢谢亚当。那么请告诉我们一些理论是如何转化为教育以及其他环境的。好的，我在攻读博士学位时遇到的一个重要理论叫做“实践社区”，全称是“学习实践社区”，你可能会认为这很适合教育领域，但它是由拉夫和温格在
1991, I think. And they actually started off in the industry, the commercial sector. And they give this very good example in their book or in their research around how to solve engineering problems. And so company A is not competitive against company B because company B has a new product. So company A has to catch up. And one of the, the way they did it was by organizing what they call communities of practice whereby they would be given a problem, which Venger calls a domain. And then they have to discuss that problem in depth. And what Venger found, as his research went deeper and deeper was that the more they discussed, the more ideas that were generated, the closer in alignment they became. So they identified together more. The stronger that
1991年左右提出的。他们最初是在工业和商业领域开始研究的。他们在书中或研究中给出了一个很好的例子，关于如何解决工程问题。A公司在与B公司的竞争中处于劣势，因为B公司有新产品。所以A公司必须赶上。他们组织了所谓的“实践社区”，即被赋予一个问题，温格称之为“领域”。然后他们必须深入讨论这个问题。温格在研究深入后发现，讨论得越多，产生的想法就越多，他们的一致性就越强。因此，他们共同的认同感更强。这种认同感越强，
identity, the greater the collaboration. But what he also found was when you introduce someone new to that community of practice, they start on the fringes and then they learn about new things within that domain and then they become closer and closer into the center of it. So the simplest way for me to take that into the education sector is a new teacher. You start off in the training sector and both you and I have been, have experienced this in our training courses. And then as you learn more about pedagogy and behavior management, emotional regulation, you then start to identify with other teachers and your identity then shifts. And it went from this sort of problem solving model to this humanistic model whereby
协作就越紧密。但他还发现，当你向那个实践社区引入新人时，他们从边缘开始，然后学习该领域内的新事物，接着他们会越来越靠近中心。对我来说，将其应用到教育领域最简单的方式就是新教师。你从培训阶段开始，你我都经历过这些培训课程。然后，随着你对教学法、行为管理、情绪调节了解得越多，你就会开始认同其他教师，你的身份认同也会随之转变。它从这种解决问题的模式转变为一种人文主义模式，即
Epicay, Venger's, whether he would like me saying this or not, it becomes very clear that in order for an organization to thrive, identity is at the core of it. One of the things I took away from that is identity is linked to well-being. Because when you enter a new community, you're being judged to a certain extent. you have to look introspectively as to what you're about and then re-evaluate that in the new context. So for children, it's transitions into key stage three. For adults, it's changing roles. It's changing jobs. Yeah, and it's evoking kind of memories of a number of professionals that I've supported
温格的理论——不管他是否喜欢我这么说——变得非常清楚：为了让一个组织蓬勃发展，身份认同是其核心。我从中得到的一点是，身份认同与幸福感有关。因为当你进入一个新社区时，你在一定程度上会被评判。你必须内省自己是什么样的人，然后在新的环境中重新评估。所以对于孩子来说，这是向关键阶段三的过渡；对于成年人来说，这是角色的转变，是工作的变动。是的，这唤起了我曾支持过的许多专业人士的记忆，
who've started new jobs and then gone through whistleblowing procedures. Because actually, when you come into an organisation with fresh eyes and I guess if we're thinking about clinical services or kind of, yeah, things that psychologists might work in, obviously people might be listening to that from other industries, but you would want a service to be effective, efficient, safe for the staff, safe for the service users, and to be not engaging in risky practice or kind of, I don't know, doing the clinical notes like in a routine way so that all of the staff can access it. And I think when you join a team for the first time,
他们换了新工作，然后经历了举报程序。因为实际上，当你带着全新的眼光进入一个组织时——我想如果我们考虑临床服务或心理学家可能工作的领域，显然其他人可能也会听——你会希望服务是有效、高效、对员工安全、对服务对象安全的，并且不参与风险实践，或者不是以那种死板的方式记录临床笔记，以便所有员工都能查阅。我认为当你第一次加入一个团队时，
that's almost the most powerful time for you to be able to really think, right, is this a safe service? Do I want my name attached to it? And if it isn't safe, then, you know, we have that impetus to do the whistleblowing procedure. But it sounds like what you're saying is that the longer you stay, the more likely you are to kind of just be warmed up into the culture of the organisation and maybe also then become part of the problem.
那是你能够真正思考“这是一个安全的服务吗？我希望我的名字与它挂钩吗？”的最有力时刻。如果它不安全，那么我们就有动力去执行举报程序。但听起来你的意思是，你待的时间越长，你就越有可能被同化进组织的文化中，甚至可能成为问题的一部分。
There's always the risk of that. You could become, you know, another con in the wheel and if it's sound too draconian corrupted yourself. And, you know, you're talking about in the extreme sense. And the extreme sense is important to pay attention to you. because we live in a world now where corporations have tremendous power to the point where some corporations are arguably stronger than states. And that has an impact because things, both you and I run small SMEs, small and medium sized enterprises. And that is a very different experience to run a corporation because in order for me to attract a team, I have to make, the value system I embody has to max the value system, the people I bring in.
这总是有风险的。你可能会成为机器里的另一个齿轮，如果听起来太严苛的话，甚至会被腐蚀。你知道，你谈论的是极端情况。关注极端情况很重要，因为我们现在生活在一个企业拥有巨大权力的世界里，以至于某些企业可以说比国家更强大。这会产生影响，因为你我都经营着小型中小企业（SME）。经营企业与经营公司是非常不同的体验，因为为了吸引团队，我体现的价值体系必须与我引入的人的价值体系相匹配。
So, for example, I need someone who's highly skilled in psychology or teaching, but who also wants to go along with the same mission statement. That has a very small pull of people. Whereas when you take a large corporation, like, I'm not saying any of these do this, but like you've got Pricewater Cooper, you've got Apple, you've got Google. they don't have to worry about the same things. They have, we're so big, therefore we can attract a lot of people in pursuit of our mission. Therefore, if you don't want to be a part of that, we just, it's the churn and burn.
例如，我需要一个在心理学或教学方面技术精湛，但同时也愿意遵循相同使命宣言的人。这样的人才库非常小。而当你面对像普华永道、苹果、谷歌这样的大公司时，他们不必担心同样的事情。他们规模很大，因此可以吸引很多人来追求他们的使命。因此，如果你不想成为其中的一部分，他们只是“用完即弃”。
You know, you turn them up and turn them out and bring in someone else. And large corporations can do that. And as employees or people on the entry level, we have to be aware of that. And we're seeing issues around that. You know, the subtext of this podcast is about well-being. And one of the things we're seeing as entry-level employees, those between the age of say 19 and 25, are struggling with their well-being.
你知道，他们招进来又踢出去，再换别人。大公司可以这样做。作为员工或入门级人员，我们必须意识到这一点。我们正在看到围绕这一点的问题。你知道，这期播客的潜台词是关于幸福感的。我们看到的一个现象是，入门级员工，比如19到25岁之间的人，正在为他们的幸福感而挣扎。
And it's too easy just to put that down to our relationships with middle management. You know, I've seen a supported organizations where that's been the case. But it is the structure of society. is changing and the speed of which it's changing with the emergence of AI is going to have a tremendous impact on well-being. And I think it's very important for people like UNI to advocate for healthy organizational systems and for the listeners of this podcast to be aware of when you enter into a new job that these are some of the risk factors and you have to be aware of your value system as to why you're doing that. Yeah, and I obviously do a lot of work for early career psychologists,
仅仅把这归咎于我们与中层管理人员的关系太简单了。我知道，我见过并支持过这样的组织。但这是社会结构正在发生变化，而随着人工智能的出现，这种变化的速度将对幸福感产生巨大影响。我认为对于像你我这样的人来说，倡导健康的组织系统，并让这期播客的听众意识到当你进入一份新工作时，这些都是一些风险因素，你必须意识到你为什么要做这件事的价值体系，这非常重要。是的，我显然为职业生涯早期的心理学家做了很多工作，
but I do speak from a position where I am not newly qualified and where I now am not employed, I am self-employed. I sometimes think, am I a CEO? Do I step into my CEO identity? And I think I'm trying to do that more and more. But also when I speak to people that are early in their career, and they're doing, you know, 37 and a half hour weeks, but they're doing maybe 30 hours of face to face clinical time, or 30 sessions, should we say, because they're not all kind of hours. That is a lot. It's a lot to hold in mind alongside MDT meetings, alongside all the clinical notes for that, alongside the risk planning, alongside, you know, what's like, Adam, when you ask the question
但我说话的立场是我已经不是刚入行的新手了，我现在不是受雇者，而是自雇者。我有时会想，我是CEO吗？我是否进入了我的CEO身份？我想我正在努力越来越多地这样做。但当我与职业生涯早期的人交谈时，他们每周工作37.5小时，但可能做了30小时面对面的临床时间，或者说30次会谈，因为它们不全是小时。这很多。在处理多学科团队会议、所有临床笔记、风险规划的同时，还要在脑海中保持这些，这真的很多。亚当，当你问这个问题时，
and you think, oh, God, I hope the answer to this is going to be, yeah, everything's fine, because I literally don't know where I'm going to have the time to make a safeguarding referral if they tell me that something's not right. And we'll have both been there when you've heard stuff. And of course, you've got that duty of care, you've got that compassion. And you want this adult or child to be safeguarded. But you also know that to fill in that documentation, it's going to probably take you two or three hours. And you're just going to have to juggle everything you've already got.
你心想，哦天哪，我希望答案是“是的，一切都很好”，因为如果他们告诉我有什么不对劲，我真的不知道我哪里有时间去提交安全保障转介。我们都经历过听到这些事情的时候。当然，你有那种关怀的责任，你有那种同情心。你希望这个成年人或孩子得到保护。但你也知道，要填写那份文件，可能需要两三个小时。你只能在已经拥有的所有工作之间进行权衡。
That is not great for the well-being, especially if you're then left holding the mental load until you can pass that on until you know that that case has been accepted for safeguarding. It isn't easy. and if you then got 30 clients that you might be having potentially to drop safeguarding concerns at any point, and then you're having to hold that in mind and access supervision, I can see why well-being is tricky. Yeah, and, you know, I don't know if you fully realize this, but you've opened up a can of worms there, and I'll try not to go too much,
这对幸福感来说并不好，特别是如果你随后还要承担心理负担，直到你能将其移交，直到你知道该案例已被安全保障部门受理。这不容易。如果你有30个客户，可能随时都要提出安全保障担忧，然后你必须在脑海中保持这些并寻求督导，我能理解为什么幸福感会变得棘手。是的，你知道，我不知道你是否完全意识到这一点，但你打开了一个潘多拉魔盒，我会尽量不深入，
but in the mid-notties, around 2005, under New Labor, there was this sort of emergence, and the NHS was, highly impacted by this of new professional managerialism. And it was the thought that you could have these professional managers manage professionals within NHS. So the likes of yourself as a clinical psychologist being managed by someone who isn't. Now, that still exists to some degree, but not entirely. There's something called hybrid professionalism that's emerging. But we'll get on to that in a moment.
但在2000年代中期，大约2005年，在新工党领导下，出现了一种趋势，NHS深受其影响，即“专业管理主义”。人们认为可以让这些专业经理来管理NHS内部的专业人员。比如像你这样的临床心理学家被一个非专业人士管理。现在，这种情况在某种程度上仍然存在，但不完全是。出现了一种叫做“混合专业主义”的东西。但我们稍后再谈。
What that meant was that you had managers enter in professional domain. and taking a reductive approach. And what they were coming in with was the Adam Smith approach of the wealth of nations. And Adam Smith was very famous for detail and how to make a bunch of needles or nails, I can't remember which, by specialising roles. The difference between our fields and other fields is that professional roles have to have an element of autonomy and application of specialised knowledge. And that is a safe, like you said, a safeguard issue.
这意味着经理们进入了专业领域，并采取了一种还原论的方法。他们带来的是亚当·斯密《国富论》的方法。亚当·斯密以通过专业化角色来制造一堆针或钉子（我不记得是哪个了）而闻名。我们领域与其他领域的区别在于，专业角色必须具备一定程度的自主权和专业知识的应用。这就像你说的，是一个安全保障问题。
So you cannot just say that your entire role as a clinical psychologist is just to do face-to-face therapy sessions. It's too reductive because, like you just highlighted, safeguarding issues can come out of that. Also, that's a huge amount of the load to sustain over a long period of time. Human problems are not machine problems. You know, a machine doesn't need a break, a human does. And that's just some of the issues. But what was happening over time was that the professional role was becoming increasingly siloed, streamlined. And it was happening in our sector too with educational psychology.
所以你不能仅仅说你作为临床心理学家的全部角色就是做面对面的治疗。这太简化了，因为正如你刚才强调的，安全保障问题可能会从中产生。此外，长期维持这种负荷是非常巨大的。人类的问题不是机器的问题。你知道，机器不需要休息，但人类需要。这只是一些问题。但随着时间的推移，专业角色变得越来越孤立、精简。这种情况在我们的教育心理学领域也发生了。
We historically spent most of our time supporting head teachers. We would do lots of dropping sessions, just checking in on people. We knew they were going through a tough time. and we would have the autonomy and competency to apply our specialized knowledge in a way we seem fit. And then with, I don't want to get into it now, because people have heard me speak about this. The Children and Families Act changed a lot of that towards assessment-driven things. And this is another aspect of moving away from communities of practice, but competency and autonomy are incredibly important for employee well-being. Now, I think we spend a lot of time looking at entry-level employees and not seeing how they progress through the system.
我们过去大部分时间都在支持校长。我们会进行很多走访，只是检查一下人们的情况。我们知道他们正在经历困难时期。我们有自主权和能力以我们认为合适的方式应用我们的专业知识。然后，随着——我不想现在深入讨论，因为人们已经听过我谈论这个了——《儿童与家庭法案》将很多东西转向了以评估为驱动的事情。这是远离实践社区的另一个方面，但能力和自主权对于员工的幸福感极其重要。现在，我认为我们花了很多时间关注入门级员工，却没有看到他们是如何在系统中进步的。
Entry-level employees need more hand-holding, so to speak, less autonomy, but they still need some level of autonomy in order to assimilate that new identity. And if you come into a role where everything is siloed and everything is, you know, procedure-driven and you only follow a screen, script, there's no growth there. There's no autonomy. So without autonomy, there's no learning. There's just, well, machine learning. You learn to replicate what the script tells you. And many jobs are falling into that trap. You know, the famous one being the call center stuff, they literally follow a script. And you get promoted based on how well you know that script. But you don't get promoted on the soft skill stuff. How do you manage conflict? How do you know, if you had a call center person who you said to them, some organizations do open up to this, but you say,
入门级员工需要更多的引导，也就是更少的自主权，但他们仍然需要一定程度的自主权来同化那种新的身份。如果你进入一个角色，一切都是孤立的，一切都是程序驱动的，你只遵循屏幕上的脚本，那里就没有成长。没有自主权。所以没有自主权，就没有学习。只有——嗯，机器学习。你学会复制脚本告诉你的内容。许多工作都陷入了那个陷阱。你知道，最著名的是呼叫中心的工作，他们字面上遵循脚本。你因为对脚本的熟悉程度而获得晋升。但你不会因为软技能而获得晋升。你如何处理冲突？你知道，如果你有一个呼叫中心人员，你对他们说——有些组织确实对此持开放态度——但你说，
we don't care if it takes two hours to do a call as long as that customer's happy, then that, you know, that's the soft market inside. It starts to filter out and, you know, you have good experiences and then that becomes your reputation. Whereas if you go through a script, like, we want you to get through 600 calls. That is the quantitative, reductive end of it. And organizations leaders, business leaders need to find out where their balance lies. You know, there's not just one way to do business. And if we're going back to the heart of this podcast, well-being, I would argue less on the metrics and more on the humanistic side of it. It's better to have five small companies where everyone's happy than one massive company where you're constantly worried about churn.
“我们不在乎打一个电话需要两个小时，只要客户满意就行”，那么，你知道，这就是软市场的内部。它开始过滤出来，你知道，你有很好的体验，然后这就成了你的声誉。而如果你走脚本，比如“我们希望你完成600个电话”，那就是量化的、还原论的终点。组织领导者、商业领袖需要找出他们的平衡点在哪里。你知道，做生意不止一种方式。如果我们回到这期播客的核心——幸福感，我会说少关注指标，多关注人文方面。拥有五家每个人都快乐的小公司，比拥有一家你不断担心人员流失的大公司要好。
Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, I think you mentioned that the old model would be that you could do consultation for people that wasn't linked to a specific piece of work and wasn't linked to assessment because you wanted to check in, you wanted to check that your schools were thriving. But also it made me think about one of the most enjoyable pieces of clinical work I ever did was when I worked during training, I worked in a service that had a weekly drop-in on a Wednesday lunchtime and any parent could either bring themselves to discuss their child's problem or to discuss a problem they were having linked to their child or they could bring their child along as well
是的，绝对是。而且，你知道，我想你提到旧模式是你可以为那些不与特定工作挂钩、不与评估挂钩的人提供咨询，因为你想检查一下，你想检查你的学校是否在蓬勃发展。但这也让我想起我做过的最令人愉快的临床工作之一，那是在培训期间，我在一个服务机构工作，每周三午餐时间有一个门诊，任何家长都可以带自己来讨论他们孩子的问题，或者讨论他们与孩子相关的问题，或者他们也可以带孩子一起来，
and they would get 20 minutes with somebody in that service to think through their problem, send them away with answers and then in the afternoon all of us clinicians would write letters summarising what had happened ceasing it to the GP, kickstarting any referrals. So we were getting in there at a really early stage and it felt so good because you were helping people with problems right then. They haven't sweated it for six months before going to the GP so it's already entrenched. So you really are able to get systemic support to kind of think with them about different ways of parents or different ways of thinking about the problem, maybe externalising the problem, recommending books, you know, sending them away with resources are like this is, if you do this,
他们会得到该服务机构某人的20分钟时间来思考他们的问题，带着答案离开，然后在下午，我们所有临床医生都会写信总结发生的事情，将其发送给全科医生（GP），启动任何转介。所以我们在一个非常早期的阶段就介入了，感觉非常好，因为你当时就在帮助人们解决问题。他们没有在去看全科医生之前纠结六个月，导致问题已经根深蒂固。所以你真的能够获得系统性的支持，与他们一起思考不同的育儿方式，或者思考问题的不同方式，也许是外化问题，推荐书籍，你知道，给他们资源，就像这样，如果你这样做，
this is going to be really, really helpful. And then they might come back. into next week's dropping, you may never see them again. But clinically, professionally, maybe egotistically, you were actually able to make change within 20 minutes. If nobody else turned up, which was rare, you could sometimes extend your session. So there'd always usually be at least one first appointment. Sometimes if there wasn't anyone else waiting, you could extend it. But the idea was, is that single session intervention to be able to be clinically helpful in 20 minutes and I loved it. So I think if I'd been working in that service still now and they took that away, that would have been a key attractor for the role, but you're not necessarily getting
这将是非常非常有帮助的。然后他们可能会回到下周的门诊，你可能再也见不到他们了。但在临床上、专业上，也许是自负地说，你确实能够在20分钟内做出改变。如果没有其他人来，这很少见，你有时可以延长你的会诊时间。所以通常至少会有一次首次预约。有时如果没有其他人等待，你可以延长它。但这个想法是，那种单次干预能够在20分钟内提供临床帮助，我喜欢它。所以我想如果我现在还在那个服务机构工作，而他们取消了它，那将是一个吸引该角色的关键因素，但你并不一定能得到
the outcomes. And I would imagine that many ed sites or people working in schools really like the ability to be able to work more informally. Think about what problems are cropping up now, to be able to make those changes rather than getting stuck with the more entrenched problems that are more task-specific, I would say. Love your thoughts on that, Adam. Absolutely. And you've just come full circle back around into autonomy. You said that in those 20 minutes,
结果。我想许多教育心理学家或在学校工作的人真的喜欢能够更非正式地工作的能力。思考现在出现了什么问题，能够做出这些改变，而不是被那些更具体的、更根深蒂固的问题所困扰。亚当，很想听听你的想法。绝对是。你刚才又回到了自主权的话题。你说在那20分钟里，
it was like a lovely piece of work that you got to do because you had the autonomy over it. Without having to worry too much about the commissioning process, the commissioning was sorted. And the cognitive load end, the reporting end, was also sorted. Similarly, I've actually embedded that into my own model whereby I allow practitioners in schools to to book 30 minutes free of charge with me.
那是一段很棒的工作，因为你拥有自主权。而不必太担心委托流程，委托已经解决了。认知负荷端、报告端也解决了。同样，我实际上已经将这一点嵌入到我自己的模式中，我允许学校的从业者预订30分钟的免费咨询。
Don't abuse the system to just talk through problems. And it's not, you know, they don't have to, they can write their own notes. But it allows me to explore in a different way that is not set in stone like through the EHCP process, which is very much you have to go through certain criteria. And you mentioned there around teachers. Increasingly, teachers are beholden to Austin regulations, the curriculum. I know I've spoken to several teachers who were seriously worried about the space between lines and their jodders based on what offsted we're going to say. And I'm going, you have five kids in this class who have serious emotional problems, can we?
不要滥用系统来谈论问题。而且，你知道，他们不必——他们可以写自己的笔记。但这允许我以一种不同的方式进行探索，而不是像通过EHCP流程那样一成不变，那是非常必须通过某些标准的。你提到了教师。教师们越来越受英国教育标准局（Ofsted）法规和课程的束缚。我知道我曾与几位教师交谈过，他们非常担心作业本上行与行之间的间距，因为Ofsted会怎么说。我说，你们班上有五个孩子有严重的情绪问题，我们可以吗？
And they just don't have the space because they're too worried about, like, like you say, the task. And what that excreed to me was, not that these were bad teachers or anything, they got quite the opposite. They're quite dedicated. But the system wasn't allowing them to be autonomous. The system wasn't allowing them to make decisions. The system wasn't allowing them to experiment. The system wasn't allowing them to learn about the children. And that perpetuates. And it's going to continue perpetuating. I don't want to get us into an offset bashing thing. But, you know, they said they're going to double down on standards. You know, the head of us that said, I'm never going to compromise on standards.
他们只是没有空间，因为他们太担心了，就像你说的，任务。这对我来说说明了什么，不是说他们是坏老师或什么，恰恰相反。他们非常敬业。但系统不允许他们自主。系统不允许他们做决定。系统不允许他们实验。系统不允许他们了解孩子。这会持续下去。而且它会继续持续下去。我不想让我们陷入抨击Ofsted的境地。但是，你知道，他们说他们要加倍提高标准。你知道，Ofsted的负责人说，我永远不会在标准上妥协。
And what they're really saying is the academic standards. You're not talking about emotional standards. You're not talking about social standards or anything like that. It's the progress aid for secondary schools and it's sat for primary schools. That's what they're talking about. Yeah, it's interesting. But I think when I reflect on one of the reels that we created for to go alongside a previous episode, I asked you what the most important thing was as a child and educational psychologist, and you didn't think it was attainment.
他们真正说的是学术标准。你不是在谈论情感标准。你不是在谈论社会标准或类似的东西。这是中学的进步指标，是小学的SAT考试。这就是他们在谈论的。是的，这很有趣。但我反思我们为配合上一集而制作的短片之一时，我问你作为一名儿童和教育心理学家，最重要的事情是什么，你认为不是成绩。
You didn't think it was, you didn't think it was grades and performance. And so there's that mismatch then between Ofsted, children and young people, teachers and families. Absolutely. And, you know, we're flipping between health, education and business. But really the themes are the same. If you don't have a motivated staff team, you don't achieve anything. You know, we measure, we try to, as a society, we try to reduce everything to metrics. And in the education sector, those metrics are attainment.
你认为不是，你认为不是分数和表现。所以Ofsted、儿童和年轻人、教师和家庭之间存在这种错位。绝对是。而且，你知道，我们在健康、教育和商业之间切换。但实际上主题是一样的。如果你没有一个积极进取的员工团队，你就什么也实现不了。你知道，我们衡量，我们试图，作为一个社会，我们试图将一切简化为指标。在教育领域，这些指标就是成绩。
Again, what underpins that attainment arguably is subjective, you know. Your GCSEs doesn't necessarily translate into IQ, does it? We know that. but when you have a dedicated staff team, you can achieve so much more. One, because fundamentally, they're coachable. What they don't know, if they're behind the mission,
同样，支撑这些成绩的东西可以说也是主观的，你知道。你的GCSE成绩并不一定转化为智商，对吧？我们知道这一点。但是当你有一个敬业的员工团队时，你可以实现更多。第一，因为从根本上说，他们是可教的。他们不知道的东西，如果他们支持使命，
they'll go to their way to learn it. They might need a bit of direction from you. However, if you've just got someone who's highly intelligent but doesn't care about, say my mission, which is the support the education sector, but they're more interested in, I don't know, Lamborghinis
他们会竭尽全力去学习。他们可能需要你的一点指导。然而，如果你有一个非常聪明但不关心，比如我的使命——支持教育领域——的人，但他们更感兴趣的是，我不知道，兰博基尼，
they're not going to get on board of everything I say, but they could have an IQ of 250 for all I know. It doesn't make a difference. And this is what we need to start thinking about in terms of organizations. It's what are the values that you have as an organization? And I don't mean the superficial kind. I mean around how you relate to each other, how you organize your teams,
他们不会支持我所说的一切，但他们的智商可能有250，我不知道。这没有区别。这就是我们需要在组织方面开始思考的问题。作为组织，你有什么价值观？我指的不是肤浅的那种。我指的是关于你们如何相互关联，如何组织团队，
how do you support autonomy, how you support competency, how do you challenge incompetency, where someone may be incompetent but doesn't have a clue that they are. And can you do that in a soft way or do you have to do that in a hard way? You know, these things matter. How, you know, HR departments are probably doing their papers in the air. We deal with this every day.
如何支持自主权，如何支持能力，如何挑战无能，当某人可能无能但根本不知道自己无能时。你能以一种温和的方式做到这一点，还是必须以一种强硬的方式？你知道，这些事情很重要。人力资源部门可能正在把他们的文件扔到空中。我们每天都在处理这个问题。
But these things are important. And, you know, your earlier anecdote around whistleblowing, why you support whistleblowers so that one, they may feel confident enough to come back to work is another thing. And obviously, I'm coming from a very biased perspective around well-being, given the nature of my job. But, you know, if your company doesn't embody that, employees should be made aware of that.
但这些事情很重要。而且，你知道，你之前关于举报的轶事，你为什么支持举报者，这样一方面，他们可能会感到足够自信回到工作岗位，这是另一回事。显然，考虑到我工作的性质，我在幸福感方面带有非常偏见的视角。但是，你知道，如果你的公司没有体现这一点，员工应该被告知这一点。
Yeah, absolutely. And even thinking about this, if people are listening, thinking how can I encourage future leaders, or how can I become more competent and confident and hopefully not incompetent at being a leader. And I think sometimes responsibilities and roles can be tightly held on to. And sometimes they can obviously flung down at you. Like, I don't want to do that, you do that.
是的，绝对是。甚至想到这一点，如果人们在听，思考我如何鼓励未来的领导者，或者我如何变得更有能力和自信，希望在成为领导者时不要无能。我认为有时责任和角色可以被紧紧抓住。有时它们显然可以被扔给你。就像，我不想做那个，你做那个。
But I think it needs to be safe. So I had this experience of being on training. And the first ever MDT meeting I went to, it was said at the end of the meeting, and the next chair of this meeting will be married. And I was like, what? Like, I haven't even, I think it was like the agenda before the meeting and even happened. I thought, why, I don't, what?
但我认为它需要是安全的。所以我曾有在培训中的经历。我参加的第一次多学科团队会议，会议结束时说，下次会议的主持人将是玛丽安。我当时想，什么？就像，我甚至认为这是会议之前的议程，甚至还没发生。我想，为什么，我不，什么？
And I just, that put me on the spot and I wasn't expecting it. And I just think that could have been handled in a different way. It could have actually, we really like our trainees to be able to learn things. We don't expect you to be perfect. And as such, we rotate the chair of this. And don't worry, we'll be sort of. And don't worry, will we support you with what you need to do? But we'd really love it if you would chair, please, Marianne.
这让我处于尴尬境地，我没预料到。我只是认为这可以用不同的方式处理。它可以是：实际上，我们真的希望我们的学员能够学习东西。我们不指望你是完美的。因此，我们轮流主持这个会议。别担心，我们会支持你做你需要做的事情。但如果你能主持，我们会很高兴，玛丽安。
Then I'd have been prepared, rather than thinking, as a trainee, I need to be perfect. And I'm being judged by all of these new people that I've never met before. It felt a little bit like being thrown under the bus. And I was spoken to about my response as well, privately, that it didn't seem very contained or professional. And I then internalised that at the time. but actually I think maybe it could have been handled in a more contained or compassionate way
那样我就有准备了，而不是作为一名学员，心想我需要完美。而且我正被所有这些我从未见过的新人评判。这感觉有点像被扔到公共汽车下。我私下里也被谈论了我的反应，说它看起来不太克制或专业。我当时内化了这一点，但实际上我认为也许它可以用一种更克制或更富有同情心的方式处理，
rather than expecting me to just juggle it. Arguably it wasn't professional how they dropped it on you. You know, you were a trainee, you're given protected status and throwing into this role and it does happen, doesn't it?
而不是指望我只是去应付。可以说，他们把它扔给你是不专业的。你知道，你是一名学员，你被赋予了受保护的身份，却被扔进这个角色，这确实发生了，不是吗？
We like to, some people like to just say, okay, the best way they learn is just to get into it. But there has to be an element of the experienced staff supporting the in-experienced staff to develop their competencies. You can't have autonomy
我们喜欢，有些人喜欢只是说，好的，他们学习的最佳方式就是投入其中。但必须有经验丰富的员工支持缺乏经验的员工发展他们的能力。你不能拥有自主权
without competency. The two speak to each other. Go and do whatever you want. That's great. But I haven't a clue where to begin with research. And you want me to be, you know, a professor of green energy or something. I couldn't do that.
而没有能力。两者是相辅相成的。“去随心所欲地做任何事。”那很好。但我对研究一窍不通。而你希望我成为，你知道，绿色能源教授什么的。我做不到。
You know what I mean? I wouldn't know where to begin. I need someone who, walk down field a bit further than I, having come along here, this is where we begin, and I'm going back to Venger's communities of practice stuff. And increasingly, we're seeing issues around entry-level well-being, and one of the aspects is probably around mentorship. And I don't mean that in the soft woolly way or your line manager has to be really warm and enticing. No, it's about gradually introducing you into an organization without a lot.
你知道我的意思吗？我不知道从哪里开始。我需要一个比我走得更远的人，沿着这条路走，这是我们开始的地方，我回到温格的实践社区理论。而且，我们越来越多地看到围绕入门级幸福感的问题，其中一个方面可能与指导有关。我指的不是那种温和模糊的方式，或者你的直线经理必须非常热情和诱人。不，这是关于在不感到不知所措的情况下，逐渐将你引入一个组织。
feeling overwhelmed. And, you know, if I leave my current role and go join another educational psychology service, I'm probably going to refine simply because I've gone into several services before. I have an expectation. As a trainee, though, that's my first time doing it. I need some sort of onboarding that will be robust. And the best onboarding I ever had was with an organization called Five Rivers. and they basically said, we're going to give you a full month with no responsibilities, but you go and get to go
而且，你知道，如果我离开我目前的角色去加入另一个教育心理学服务机构，我可能会因为之前去过几个服务机构而感到轻松。我有一个期望。然而，作为一名学员，那是我的第一次。我需要某种稳健的入职培训。我经历过的最好的入职培训是在一家名为Five Rivers的组织，
and work with all these people who will then be leading. So the people who I would be leading were actually leading me first. So we got to build a rapport, got to build a relationship, I understood the roles in greater depth, and it led to some fabulous work around social care
他们基本上说，我们要给你整整一个月的时间，没有任何责任，但你可以去和所有这些人一起工作，他们随后将成为领导者。所以那些我将要领导的人实际上是在先领导我。所以我们建立了融洽的关系，建立了联系，我更深入地了解了这些角色，这导致了一些关于社会护理的精彩工作，
and how to support foster care. And so like this idea being a leader whereby you need to make all the decisions and have some sort of authority over others that that kind of needs to leave we're in a world not a digital world we're in a world where by people are very aware of their well-being people are very aware of their identities you know the term identity politics is is a given term now whereas it wasn't when I was a child and companies and organizations need to accept that and move with it
以及如何支持寄养。所以，这种作为领导者需要做出所有决定并对他人拥有某种权威的想法，那种东西需要离开。我们生活在一个世界里，不是数字世界，我们生活在一个人们非常关注自己的幸福感、非常关注自己的身份认同的世界里。你知道，“身份政治”这个词现在是一个既定术语，而我小时候不是这样。公司和组织需要接受这一点并随之改变。
I get sent books all the time around leadership. And the overwhelming theme is that people want to move towards a more compassionate form of it. Some people do it well. Some people articulate it very well. And others don't. In the education sector, we talk a lot about compassion. But then when you actually see the pressure that they're under, it's hard for these leaders to actually embody that. And they burn out.
我一直收到关于领导力的书籍。压倒性的主题是人们想要走向一种更具同情心的领导形式。有些人做得很好。有些人表达得很好。而另一些人则不然。在教育领域，我们谈论了很多关于同情心。但当你真正看到他们所承受的压力时，这些领导者很难真正体现这一点。他们精疲力竭。
Yeah, and it again reminds me of that really lovely term that I first heard in Gabel-Mate's book, the emotional collection of people. And when we're joining workforces, if we're expected to kind of be working under someone more senior than us, it's actually really lovely to be able to give chances to see that person operate so that you are emotionally collected by them, but also, you want to work hard for them because you respect them and you like the way they work and you want to do well. And I think the same happens in schools as well. If the teacher has that experience, the child wants to work hard for you rather than just putting on the thumb screws as soon as the
是的，它再次让我想起我在加博·马特的书中第一次听到的那个非常可爱的词：人们的情感收集。当我们加入劳动力队伍时，如果我们被期望在比我们资深的人手下工作，能够有机会看到那个人运作实际上真的很好，这样你就会被他们情感上收集，而且，你想要为他们努力工作，因为你尊重他们，你喜欢他们的工作方式，你想要做得好。我认为在学校里也是如此。如果老师有那种经验，孩子会想为你努力工作，而不是一旦……就拧紧螺丝。
child joins and then it all going to pot and then having to rebuild. So I think, yeah, when we're joining organisations or if you have people joining your organisation, I think really thinking about having this chance to cultivate a relationship, even if you've got someone just with you for a short period of time. So I know that, you know, trainee nurses might only be with people on placement for 10 weeks. And an assistant psychologist might be just, you know, a few months, a year, maybe a little longer. Trainees might be four to five months. But what if we can do our job so well that these people then want to come back when they're qualified to work in our team because they love what we do, what we achieve and the way we make them feel in that organisation as a valued part of the team.
孩子加入后，一切都可能变得混乱，然后不得不重建。所以我认为，是的，当我们加入组织，或者当有人加入你的组织时，我认为真的要考虑创造一个培养关系的机会，即使某人只是和你在一起很短的时间。我知道，你知道，实习护士可能只在实习期间和人们在一起10周。助理心理学家可能只是，你知道，几个月，一年，也许再长一点。实习生可能是四到五个月。但如果我们能把工作做得这么好，这些人以后在获得资格后，会因为热爱我们的工作、我们的成就以及我们在组织中让他们感受到作为团队重要一员的方式，而愿意回到我们的团队工作，那会怎样呢？
And there's a really nice podcast that I think I'm going to try and run called, you know, mattering. And I think that's part of this kind of conversation as well. In order to thrive in any organisation, whether it's a family, whether it's, you know, as a parent, whether it's in a school, whether it's in an organisation you're delivering healthcare, you need to feel like you matter. Yeah, you need to have a defined role. And I don't mean that in the role of this is what we're giving you. It's a role that you embody yourself.
有一个非常好的播客，我想我打算尝试运营，叫做“重要性”（mattering）。我认为这也是这种对话的一部分。为了在任何组织中茁壮成长，无论是家庭，还是作为父母，还是在学校，或者是在你提供医疗服务的组织中，你需要感到自己很重要。是的，你需要有一个明确的角色。我指的不是那种“这是我们给你的”角色。这是一个你自己体现出来的角色。
Going back to what we said about identity, identity and role interlinked. They're not exactly the same because when you're a child, you can have identity, but your role is being a student and a child essentially. And they're pretty much brought everybody at your age. growth fulfills that but once you enter into adulthood you start to take on roles you know you take on different professions you might become a parent you
回到我们关于身份的话题，身份和角色是相互关联的。它们并不完全相同，因为当你还是个孩子时，你可以有身份，但你的角色本质上是学生和孩子。它们在你的年龄段几乎把每个人都带到了这里。成长满足了这一点，但一旦你进入成年期，你开始承担角色，你知道，你从事不同的职业，你可能会成为父母，你
might become a care and these roles then influence how you see yourself and how you see yourself matters because when you feel a particular way about yourself you then behave in a particular way you know basic CBT and when we think about Rose Fenger was ahead of the game in my opinion around this because he understood that a role is developed by how you interact with other people, not based on what your job criteria is. And then how you take that role and extrapolate out into autonomy and competency, whereby I'm interacting with George, Susan, and they're teaching me different things. I'm taking nuggets from each of them and I'm changing how they see the role.
可能会成为照顾者，这些角色随后会影响你看待自己的方式，而你看待自己的方式很重要，因为当你对自己有某种感觉时，你就会以某种方式行事，你知道，这是基本的CBT。当我们想到Rose Fenger时，我认为他在这一点上走在了前面，因为他明白角色是通过你如何与他人互动来发展的，而不是基于你的工作标准是什么。然后你如何将那个角色外推到自主性和能力上，即我正在与George、Susan互动，他们正在教我不同的东西。我从他们每个人身上汲取精华，我正在改变他们看待这个角色的方式。
by embodying it in a slightly different way, by bringing my own knowledge to the rule, my own actions, my own interactions, and then I'm going to change that into something slightly different. We're all called, say, they're technicians. They're all called technicians, but they have slightly different takes on problem solving, and that creates new knowledge.
通过以稍微不同的方式体现它，通过将我自己的知识、我自己的行动、我自己的互动带入规则，然后我将把它改变成稍微不同的东西。我们都被称为，比如说，他们是技术员。他们都被称为技术员，但他们在解决问题上有稍微不同的看法，这创造了新的知识。
And when you jointly create new knowledge, that's a really rewarding experience. If you look at F1 teams, particularly the pick crews, they work intensively together. They solve problems and they become closer aligned because of it. Then, you know, within, say, like you said, assistant psychologists, you know, they have to gently enter into the profession. But at the same time, there can't be such a jump between their role and the role of a clinical
当你共同创造新知识时，那是一种非常有益的体验。如果你看看F1车队，特别是维修站工作人员，他们在一起紧密工作。他们解决问题，并因此变得更加紧密。然后，你知道，在，比如说，像你说的，助理心理学家，你知道，他们必须温和地进入这个行业。但与此同时，他们的角色和临床
psychologist or an educational psychologist. Because if that jumps too big, then the, the competency. element becomes under attack and then the identity element comes under attack because they feel that they can't cope. If they feel it can't cope, then the role suffers. So you've got, as an organization, you've got to think of, it's not about just fulfilling this skill set and that skill set. It's about how these skill sets interact with each other. And that is a much trickier thing to do. And it takes a lot of patience and no Chachy BT will not tell you the right answer. I love that. And you've really nicely given us a framework for something I speak about a lot.
心理学家或教育心理学家的角色之间不能有太大的跨度。因为如果那个跨度太大，那么能力要素就会受到攻击，然后身份要素也会受到攻击，因为他们觉得他们无法应对。如果他们觉得无法应对，那么角色就会受损。所以作为一个组织，你必须考虑到，这不仅仅是关于满足这个技能组合和那个技能组合。这是关于这些技能组合如何相互作用。这是一件更棘手的事情。这需要很大的耐心，而且ChatGPT不会告诉你正确的答案。我喜欢这一点。你真的很好地为我经常谈论的事情提供了一个框架。
And it's that idea that when you're going through your career, especially if you're, you know, in a training role or you're just in the number of teams for a short period of time, it's that idea of talk the talk and walk the walk in that service. Try and use some of the approaches that they want you to use. But also know that ultimately you will take with you what is a good fit for you. but you'll also have blended it and made sure that it works for you and the clients that you work with and the teams you're alongside. And then ultimately when you look back at your career, I think any of us now, if we just took a moment to look back at our career and some of the things that we do now, if we were to think, well, where did that start? Where did I first see that? It might be so much earlier in our career, but it's stayed with us and we've made it our own and we've helped new people to experience that as well. And it's just really powerful because we're not, we're never a finished clinician, are we? And I think if you are, I would invite you to consider whether it's time to retire because
这就是那个想法，当你经历你的职业生涯时，特别是如果你，你知道，处于一个培训角色，或者你只是在短时间内处于多个团队中，这就是在那个服务中“说一套做一套”（talk the talk and walk the walk）的想法。尝试使用一些他们希望你使用的方针。但也知道，最终你会带走适合你的东西。但你也会融合它，并确保它对你、你合作的客户以及你身边的团队有效。然后最终当你回顾你的职业生涯时，我想我们现在的任何人，如果我们花点时间回顾我们的职业生涯以及我们现在所做的一些事情，如果我们思考，嗯，那是从哪里开始的？我第一次在哪里看到那个？它可能在我们职业生涯的早期，但它留在了我们身边，我们已经把它变成了我们自己的，我们也帮助新人体验到了这一点。这真的非常强大，因为我们从来都不是一个“完成的”临床医生，不是吗？我想如果你是，我会邀请你考虑是否是时候退休了，因为
I don't think I'll ever be finished. All right, Adam, just before we finish, let's think a little bit about how, in your opinion, AI is threatening competency and autonomy. Oh, the AI debate is an important one. So when you interact with AI, it does things, at least on a superficial level, very well. As an entry level employee, you will feel that you are not as competent as an AI output. AI is very good at helping those in the middle level of their career or the late level of their career be more productive. So the societal dilemma is how do we implement AI to onboard.
我不认为我永远会是“完成的”。好了，Adam，在我们结束之前，让我们思考一下，在你看来，人工智能是如何威胁能力和自主性的。哦，人工智能辩论是一个重要的话题。所以当你与人工智能互动时，它至少在表面层面上做得非常好。作为一名入门级员工，你会觉得你不如人工智能的输出有能力。人工智能非常擅长帮助那些处于职业生涯中期或后期的人提高生产力。所以社会的困境在于我们如何实施人工智能来引导
new people. So for people who are experiencing threats around AI, they're going to experience things with their identity. Am I good enough to do this job? Say they're being a solicitor. This AI machine can do everything I can do and it can do it quicker. And this is threatened in my competency and it also makes me think I can't do anything myself without AI. The important thing to remember is that AI cannot do creativity to the level that a human can. And that's is where we are different. We have to focus on the application of knowledge. You and I as psychologists, AI can do a lot of the superficial stuff we can, but it cannot unpick the deep-rooted stuff. The number of times are this type in, this is coming up, and gives me some sort of superficial response. Like, you forgot this part. I said, yes, I did. That is the
新人。所以对于那些正在经历围绕人工智能威胁的人来说，他们将经历关于他们身份的事情。我足够好做这份工作吗？假设他们是一名律师。这个人工智能机器可以做我能做的一切，而且它能做得更快。这威胁到了我的能力，也让我觉得没有人工智能我什么都做不了。要记住的重要一点是，人工智能无法达到人类那样的创造力水平。这就是我们不同的地方。我们必须专注于知识的应用。你和我作为心理学家，人工智能可以做很多我们能做的表面工作，但它无法解开根深蒂固的东西。我输入这个，这个出现了，它给了我某种表面的回应。就像，你忘了这部分。我说，是的，我确实忘了。这就是
difference between a professional and AI. There was a at the entry level, work with your middle and your late career colleagues and how to apply knowledge. It is not about just being smart and recall in your university stuff. It's taking that and revisiting in a different way, going back to communities of practice, how we talk to each other matters. It really does. And AI is, I would think, infinitely more frustrating than humans are but my husband may disagree if it comes to living with me. Adam, thank you so much for your time. Let's just have a little think about where we can find you on social media and please do tell us about your podcast and website too. Great, thank you. Social media, you can get me on LinkedIn and
专业人士和人工智能的区别。在入门阶段，与你的中期和后期职业同事一起工作，以及如何应用知识。这不仅仅是关于聪明和回忆你的大学知识。这是采取这些知识并以不同的方式重新审视它，回到实践社区，我们如何相互交谈很重要。它确实很重要。而且人工智能，我想，比人类要令人沮丧得多，但如果涉及到和我住在一起，我丈夫可能会不同意。Adam，非常感谢你的时间。让我们稍微思考一下我们在社交媒体上哪里可以找到你，也请告诉我们你的播客和网站。好的，谢谢。社交媒体，你可以在LinkedIn和
Instagram. Just type of my name, Dr. Adam McCartney and I should come up. My website is Dr. Adam McCartney.com. I particularly invite you to come and look at that if you are in the education sector. And then my podcast with Mike Lane is between two sites. Our listenership is growing. We're very excited by it. And we've recently cracked 1,000 views and we're on our way to 2,000 very quickly. So we're very happy with that. Congratulations.
Instagram上找到我。只需输入我的名字，Dr. Adam McCartney，我就应该会出现。我的网站是Dr. Adam McCartney.com。如果你在教育部门，我特别邀请你来看看。然后我和Mike Lane的播客是“Between Two Sikes”。我们的听众群正在增长。我们对此感到非常兴奋。我们最近突破了1000次观看，我们很快就要达到2000次了。所以我们对此非常高兴。恭喜。
I am looking forward to come. and recording an episode with you soon too. Thank you for your time. And if people are finding this episode helpful, please do tag us on our social media, screenshot, tag us in your stories. We would love to hear from you. Thank you so much for your time, Adam. Thank you for having me again. You're so welcome. Thank you again for listening or watching. If you don't already follow or subscribe to the show, Psychology Actually, please do so now. And whilst you're in your phone tapping away subscribing and following doing all that stuff why not check out dr adam mccartney's podcast to between two sikes if you are an aspiring psychologist i think
我很期待很快也和你录制一集。谢谢你的时间。如果人们觉得这一集有帮助，请在我们的社交媒体上标记我们，截图，在你的故事中标记我们。我们很乐意收到你的来信。非常感谢你的时间，Adam。再次感谢你邀请我。不客气。再次感谢收听或观看。如果你还没有关注或订阅这个节目，“Psychology Actually”，请现在就这样做。当你拿着手机点击订阅和关注做所有这些事情时，为什么不看看Dr. Adam McCartney的播客“Between Two Sikes”呢？如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，我想
you will love the aspiring psychologist membership which you can join from just 30 pounds a month with no minimum term and whoever you are and whatever you're listening i think you'll also really like my behind the scenes kind of you know it's like just sitting down and having a coffee with me inner work episodes, which you can access via Apple Podcasts, YouTube and Patreon. And on Patreon, you can even check out little snippets of the show for free. And on Apple, you can get a free, three-day trial. I would love it if you would let me know what you think to the content. Let me know if you've got any ideas for episodes, which you can do by coming and contacting and communicating with me on any of my social media platforms. I am Dr. Marianne Trent,
你会喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership），你每月只需30英镑就可以加入，没有最低期限。无论你是谁，无论你在听什么，我想你也会非常喜欢我的幕后花絮，你知道，就像坐下来和我喝杯咖啡一样的内心工作剧集，你可以通过Apple Podcasts、YouTube和Patreon访问。在Patreon上，你甚至可以免费查看节目的小片段。在Apple上，你可以获得为期三天的免费试用。如果你能让我知道你对内容的看法，我会很高兴。如果你有任何关于剧集的想法，请告诉我，你可以通过在我的任何社交媒体平台上联系和与我交流来做到这一点。我是Dr. Marianne Trent，
Hi, I'm Max and a worker's assistant psychologist in the learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that angle in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful.
嗨，我是Max，是西约克郡学习障碍服务部门的一名助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在慢慢但肯定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，即进入临床博士课程。考虑到这一点，我想看看外面有什么，看看哪些书可能对这个有帮助。我偶然发现了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并决定这对我的旅程将是一个巨大的帮助。我发现Marianne的书非常丰富，最有洞察力。
I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我特别喜欢这些故事如何向我保证，你不需要在学术上完美才能成为一名心理学家，只要你有良好的人际交往能力，如同情心和共情能力，你就会成功。我会强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家推荐这本书，也向那些想更多地了解临床心理学世界的人推荐，它让我有一天想在那个领域工作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。